et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Christian Estrosi bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous maire de Nice
vice-président d'horizon le parti dirigé
par Édouard Philippe en étant ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
avec Denis carro à mes côtés bonjour
Denis directeur des rédactions du groupe
Nice-Matin
Christian Estrosi est-ce que vous avez
regardé le débat hier soir entre les
trois candidats à la présidence des
républicains pourquoi ça ne vous
intéresse plus ce qui se passe dans
votre ancienne famille politique
j'ai peut-être eu à faire le soir
de famille vous avez été attaché qui qui
ferait le meilleur président entre le
public
et lire rapidement le matin en diagonale
un résumé de toute l'actualité de toutes
les formations politiques de toutes les
réformes en cours
je suis aujourd'hui sur un livre de
Sylvain Tesson qui s'appelle le blanc
c'est tout son parcours de toutes les
ascensions des Alpes du Sud et de je ne
sais combien de sommets que j'ai
moi-même parcouru et je trouve que ce
livre est magnifique et donc le soir je
lis les chapitres les uns après les
autres voilà vous détendre ma journée
par Éric Ciotti ça vous surprendra pas
attaquer
Bruno je te le dis avec amitié on en a
souvent parlé que ta première
vice-présidence du groupe LR madame
Estrosi au Sénat a refusé dans notre
département de soutenir nos candidats il
y a une jeune élu ici Christelle
dentorni à la battu une candidate
macroniste dans la circonscription de
Monsieur Estrosi le nouveau maître est à
long du macronisme qui a trahi nos
valeurs est-ce que vous répondez à ça
sonne d'accord d'abord ça n'est pas mon
épouse
et
troisièmement sur les affiches de cette
fameuse madame natorni soutenue par
Madame Estrosi sa sonne alors voyez
je crois que pour le personnage qui
vient de s'exprimer tous les mensonges
sont bons ça c'est pas
Christian Estrosi le nouveau maître du
macroniste qui a créé nos valeurs ça
c'est bon ce vous m'interrogez pas sur
ce qui s'est passé au rassemblement
national pour élire un nouveau président
vous ne m'interrogez pas sur ce qui va
se passer aux parties socialistes dans
son congrès au mois de janvier prochain
donc si j'ai à parler d'une formation
politique c'est plus de l'offre que nous
avons à proposer aux Français du parti
qui me semble le plus moderne parce que
c'est le seul vous voyez il y avait que
trois parlementaires dans ce débat
il se trouve que nous nous sommes une
formation politique présidée par un
maire Monsieur Édouard Philippe le maire
du Havre dont le secrétaire général est
un maire Monsieur
BECHU qui est le maire d'Angers et dont
le vice-président est un maire le maire
de Nice on a plutôt fait le choix de
s'appuyer sur ce qui
participe à la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens et de cette relation directe
qu'il y a avec les électeurs de notre
pays et leur vrai vécu donc c'est ça
notre modernité
libéral social et qui à mon avis à
vocation d'ailleurs à attendre la main à
tous ceux des républicains qui se
sentent très mal à l'aise face à l'image
qu'on peut faire ces trois personnages
pour demain nous aider à constituer une
majorité de droite et du centre dans
notre pays et assuré et assuré la
réussite du mandat du Président de la
République Emmanuel Macron parce que si
ce mandat échoué c'est la France toute
entière qui échourée plutôt que de se
livrer des critiques stériles et
stupides au quotidien et pour vous votre
partie peut tirer profit ce qui se passe
chez les républicains est-ce que
horizons peut gagner des adhérents des
élus avec cette course à la présidence
je n'ai pas du tout envie de polémiquer
sur de l'immédiateté politicienne qui ne
m'intéresse pas
on va continuer à parler des élus et
d'Emmanuel Macron oui Emmanuel Macron ne
prononcera pas le discours du Congrès
des Maires il sera présent sur le salon
des mers demain est-ce que c'est un
mauvais signal envoyé au maire de France
mais
le président de la République est au
relation avec les maires au quotidien
c'est 365 jours sur 365 congrès des mers
c'est quoi c'est un socialiste monsieur
leigniel
droitier qui a remplacé un autre
droitier qui se livre depuis des années
contre tous les gouvernements successifs
voilà et je dis qu'elle est plutôt à la
rencontre des mers les salués dans les
allées dans les stands moi-même je
recevrai le président de la République
demain sur le stand d'une entreprise qui
s'appelle kermap et qui accompagne les
villes qui aujourd'hui végétalisent et
qui se un programme qui s'appelle un
habitant arbres nous sommes deux villes
identifiés en France à faire ce
programme c'est la ville de Nice et
c'est la ville d'Annecy j'aurai
l'occasion de l'accueillir là tout comme
cet après-midi avec Édouard Philippe
nous ferons le tour des allées de tous
ces stands où on rencontre beaucoup plus
de maire et on échange un par un
longuement on les écoute c'est important
plutôt que un discours ça aurait pas été
l'occasion de parler à ses élus locaux
de la part du président pour rendre la
vie des territoires comprendre la vie
des collectivités locales c'est s'y
attarder 365 jours sur 365 c'est pas à
écouter un long discours ou
naturellement il y a des choses à
entendre mais qu'on peut entendre dans
des circonstances plus constructives et
justement Christian Estrosi vous êtes
désormais vice-président d'horizon le
parti d'Édouard Philippe et vous êtes
président de l'Assemblée des mers en
quoi cela consiste-t-il quel est le rôle
de cette assemblée
d'horizon que nous avons fondé avec
Édouard Philippe qui aujourd'hui nous
conduit avoir des statuts on est le seul
parti en France qui est des statues qui
s'inspirent des territoires aujourd'hui
voyez bien que tous les partis
politiques
ont leurs organes de direction qui sont
organisées
à partir de ce c'est-à-dire des
parlementaires pour lesquels lesquels
j'ai eu le respect nous avons de très
bons parlementaires et notamment
l'assemblée présidé par
Laurent Marc Angélil maire d'Ajaccio un
ancien maire lui aussi
qui
se réunissent entre 11h et midi tous les
mardis à l'Assemblée ou au Sénat et le
soir à 18h au siège du parti c'est à
dire que on passe de l'un à l'autre et
on reste enfermé dans cette espèce de
choses qui ressemble quelquefois un
théâtre d'ombre où on des pires des
images qui sont envoyés aux Français sur
ce qui est devenu le débat politique
dans notre pays et nous on a plutôt fait
le choix
d'associer par le monter territoire
responsable économique
pour avoir le retour de la vraie France
de la réalité de ce qui s'ouvre dans le
monde dans l'entreprise dans le monde
des salariés dans le monde des agents
des services publics dans les activités
familiales dans le bénévolat
c'est à dire qu'on a voulu faire un
parti qui permette aux Français de faire
remonter
la réalité de leur difficulté pour du
coup comme vous écoutez les remontées
des choses mais voyez non mais vous
commencez
des élus Christ
c'est la France par exemple où il faut
impérativement arriver à moins 25%
d'empreintes carbone en 2026 c'est la
France
et vous qui êtes un maire David lisner
il demande une grande loi de
décentralisation le thème du Congrès des
mers cette année c'est le pouvoir agir
est-ce que vous le soutenez dans cette
demande de loi de décentralisation le
Girondins que je suis et qui depuis des
années se bat pour qu'il y ait un choc
de ces décentralisation ne peut que se
réjouir qu'enfin il y ait des gens qui
aujourd'hui en bois de ce pas et vous le
dites enfin c'est un raté ça d'Emmanuel
Macron qui n'a pas réussi à faire cette
décentralisation tous les gouvernements
successifs il y a eu une grande loi de
décentralisation c'était Gaston de fer
je vous le rappelle en
ça a été ensuite
Jean-Pierre Raffarin
au début des années 2000 le deuxième
quinquennat de Jacques Chirac après son
premier septennat nous avons Nicolas
Sarkozy qui sur l'intercommunalité a eu
le courage de passer à l'étape de la
métropolisation pour que nous ayons
entre la ruralité et grand centre
urbains des territoires de solidarité
Emmanuel Macron il faut
[Musique]
enfin la loi maptam qui a été
intéressante et enfin la loi la plus
intéressante de toutes qui s'appuie déjà
sur ses réformes c'est celle voulue par
Emmanuel Macron qui est la loi 3DS et
cette loi 3DS m'intéresse beaucoup
pourquoi parce qu'au moment où on
demande un choc de décentralisation moi
j'aime bien les expérimentations et la
loi 3DS voulue par Emmanuel Macron et
celle qui propose qu'il y ait des
expérimentations c'est toujours mieux
d'essayer de voir s'il y a quelque chose
qui marche plutôt que de se lancer dans
quelque chose qui va vous conduire dans
le mur or il se trouve que peu de
collectivités si ce n'est pas du tout ne
saisissent aujourd'hui l'opportunité qui
nous est offerte par cette loi d'essayer
au cas par cas voyez par exemple nous
nous sommes en train avec la Métropole
Nice Côte d'Azur de monter un dossier
pour que nous puissions avoir un droit à
l'expérimentation en matière de
transition écologique nous avons l'eau
nous avons le soleil nous avons la
géothermie nous avons la filière bois
nous avons la valeur des déchets nous
voulons pouvoir avoir un transfert de
compétences sur tous ces sujets sur les
énergies renouvelables de même que la
ville de Nice dans le domaine de la
police demande à ce qu'une partie du
régalien lui soit transféré moi j'en ai
assez par exemple d'avoir
à se solliciter un tribu administratif
ou un tribunal judiciaire pendant des
mois voire des années pour pouvoir
expulser des squatteurs là où je veux
que ce soit le maire quand on vient
casser les pieds dans un quartier et
occupé un immeuble sans droit ni titre
qui doit décider immédiatement si droit
on doit expulser ou pas régalien pour
décider moi-même pour qu'on puisse ainsi
agir en faveur de nos concitoyens si il
y a un plaignant qui n'est pas content
alors à posteriori il va faire un
recours devant les tribunaux mais pas me
faire perdre six mois un an pour pouvoir
obtenir de tels résultats et bien la loi
3DS peut parfaitement permettre au
gouvernement aujourd'hui en matière de
décentralisation de me donner de pouvoir
régaler et plus de pouvoir régalir vous
savez le régalien pour moi c'est pas une
affaire qui appartient à l'État ça peut
parfaitement se partager entre l'État et
la collectivité territoriale en matière
de d'environnement à quoi pourrait
ressembler une expérimentation qu'est-ce
que vous demandez aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
que vous aimeriez faire à Nice lundi
dernier Elisabeth borne a annoncé que la
région sud serait pilote en maternes en
matière de planification écologique
qu'est-ce que vous demandez pour que ça
ressemble à ça à Nice est dans la
métropole je vous l'ai dit l'objectif
vous voyez bien de lycaro ou qui
dirigeait un grand quotidien qui a eu à
gérer et à couvrir la tempête Alex ces
dernières années 70 jours sans pluie cet
été
vous rendez compte par exemple sur
qui est une ressource précieuse nous
n'en manquons pas parce que nous sommes
structurés et même nous ont apporté
notre contribution la Principauté de
Monaco et la communauté d'agglomération
de Menton pour les fournir en eau
puisqu'à l'échelle des 51 communes de
notre métropole nous avons sur l'eau
dont nous avons la compétence réussie
ces dernières années à nous structurer
mais le préfet a pris un arrêté pour
nous interdire d'arroser les espaces
publics et les espaces verts il nous
suffirait aujourd'hui que vous dites
laissez-nous faire il nous suffirait
aujourd'hui d'utiliser 7% de traitement
des eaux usées produits par la station
de traitement de la ville de Nice pour
pouvoir arroser et donc faire des
économies on les recyclant l'ensemble de
nos espaces verts et faire la propreté
de l'ensemble de nos rues et de nos
routes c'est un exemple mais l'écologie
c'est une affaire transversale j'entends
ceux qui parlent d'écologie en matière
d’eau ceux qui parlent d'énergie en
matière énergies renouvelables ceux qui
parlent d'énergie en matière de mobilité
c'est un tout on sait très bien que pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone en 2050
pour arriver à moins 55% en 2030 il faut
mettre en oeuvre un plan climat comme
celui que nous mettons en œuvre qui
travaille à la fois sur l'isolation
thermique qui travaille à la fois sur la
multiplication des énergies
renouvelables et la possibilité de
facturer à nos entreprises comme à nos
concitoyens le prix de l'énergie au prix
où nous la produisons quand on fait de
la géothermie dans la plaine du Var par
exemple elle coûte 50% à produire de
moins que ce que les déesses facturent
aujourd'hui et bien je veux renforcer
l'attractivité de mon territoire et
puisque j'investis sur la géothermie
pouvoir en même temps faire en sorte que
ça coûte moins cher pour mes foyers et
que ça coûte moins cher pour des
entreprises qui viendront s'installer
chez nous et créer des emplois on nous
laisse faire et en même temps nous
ferons baisser l'empreinte carbone qui
fera que sur les maladies
cardiovasculaire sur les maladies dues
en l'environnement et on en parle de
plus en plus les perturbateurs
endocriniens nous ont été justement la
santé publique grâce à des politiques
locales
et d'écologie est-ce que vous êtes
favorable un droit de veto des mers sur
la question des éoliennes mais je veux
que les mères est un droit de veto sur
tout ce qu'on voudrait leur imposer sur
l'ensemble de leurs territoires que ce
soit les éoliennes ou d'autres domaines
vous prenez toujours le petit bout de la
lauriere
c'est que nous savons que nous serons
protégés au plan énergétique grâce à ce
qu'avait Lancel général de Gaulle
Pompidou Giscard c'est-à-dire le
nucléaire civil mais il faut pas
s'enfermer sur un seul sujet
par exemple on peut se dire 50-55 60 %
de nucléaires civils et à côté de ça
avoir diversification en fonction de la
géographie en fonction du climat des
territoires sur le solaire sur
l'hydroélectrique sur les éoliennes sur
la géothermie sur l'utilisation de là où
le marine et des micro-algues sur la
valorisation des déchets il faut pas se
laisser enfermer dans une seule case par
contre vous dire qu'en matière d'eau il
est regrettable que notre pays est mis
un terme il y a quelques années de cela
à la seule énergie que vous pouvez
débloquer en une seconde on nous annonce
des coupures d'eau et de l'électricité
et s'il y a des coupures d'électricité
il suffit d'ouvrir une vanne si vous
avez des réserves d'eau dans un barrage
par exemple ou sur des chutes d'eau sur
une prise hydroélectrique sur un cours
d'eau pour pouvoir tout de suite
remettre en service l'alimentation
énergétique voilà pourquoi je souhaite
que nous ayons aussi une grande
politique hydro-électrique dans notre
pays aux côtés du nucléaire civil sur la
question des finances gros sujets de la
préoccupation majeure des des maires
aujourd'hui c'est leur budget est-ce que
vous êtes inquiet pour le vôtre à la
ville de Nice à la Métropole Nice Côte
d'Azur est-ce que vous avez des marges
de manœuvre et est-ce que vous avez
encore le pouvoir d'agir ou est-ce qu'il
faudra imaginer comme ça se fait
ailleurs augmenter la taxe foncière mais
naturellement je suis inquiet je vais
pas vous dire le contraire on n'a pas
encore tous les indicateurs une des
ressources qui pour nous est la plus
importante à l'échelle métropolitaine
c'est la CVAE la contribution sur la
valeur ajoutée des entreprises que nous
n'avons pas augmenté ces dernières
années mais parce que nous sommes un
territoire extrêmement compétitif ou
beaucoup d'entreprises s'installent et
où nous créons beaucoup d'emplois avec
en plus de ça de grandes écoles qui
viennent s'installer chez nous et qui
inspire la jeunesse à prendre des
emplois au terme de leur certification
et de leurs qualifications dans des
entreprises locales je n'y vois pas
encore très clair sur ce qui pouvez
remplacer la CVE moi je suis favorable
par exemple à ce que ce soit la TVA
parce que la TVA on sait que c'est une
recette qui peut nous garantir des
ressources de manière constante bon il y
a des impôts dont il faut revoir aussi
la physionomie
ce qu'on appelle les DMTO c'est-à-dire
les droits de mutation qui viennent sur
les transactions
immobilières vous trouvez que c'est
normal que les DMTO qui enrichissent les
conseils départementaux dans notre pays
alors que ce ne sont pas eux qui font et
qui établissent les plans locaux
d'urbanisme
intercommunaux aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire
ce cri crée la dynamique pour qu'il y
ait des transactions immobilières ce
sont les départements qui l'encaissent
aujourd'hui il suffirait que il y a un
impôt qui est corresponde à l'activité
aux compétences qui sont exercées par la
collectivité les DMTO ça correspond à
l'activité qui est menée par une
intercommunalité c'est elle qui définit
les conditions d'urbanisme et donc
d'aménagement immobilier et donc de
transactions immobilières et je pense
que là où les départements ont des
compétences sociales l'urbanisme c'est
pas son sujet donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut une recette plus juste et plus
équivalente à la compétence du
Département plus juste et plus
alignés sur les compétences des
intercommunalités et des communes plus
juste et plus correspondant aux
compétences des régions ou pour le coup
ces recettes sont basées exclusivement
sur la TVA et je trouve c'est que c'est
plutôt une bonne dynamique c'est pour ça
que les régions
ont un budget en croissance chaque année
parce que la TVA est un impôt en
croissance chaque année donc je pense
qu'il y a une révision globale de la
fiscalité locale qui permettrait en même
temps de ne pas se poser cette question
sur faut-il ou pas augmenter à la
fiscalité il y a une question
d'actualité qui concerne aussi votre
département Alpes-Maritimes c'est la
question de la politique migratoire on a
vu ce qui s'est passé avec le chêne
Viking ou la majorité des migrants ont
été remis en liberté foot de décision de
justice qui n'ont pas pu statuer à temps
sur leur cas la justice a été débordée
les 26 mineurs non accompagnés ont fugué
est-ce que l'État a failli sur ce
dossier pour vous je pense que ça
n'était pas un très bon message voilà
maintenant le gouvernement français
avait obtenu une bonne décision puisque
elle consistait à ce que à 11 pays
européens on se partage
le fait que la France est accueilli
l'océan Viking mais le mauvais message
pour être clair c'est le fait d'avoir
fait à cause de ce bateau à Toulon
ça peut donner des exemples à d'autres
bon moi je suis que pour que dans cette
affaire d'abord on saisisse l'océan
Viking comme on avait saisi l'Aquarius
il y a quelques années de cela que l'on
poursuit devant les tribunaux SOS
Méditerranée qui se sont fait les relais
de
tout ça est un système qui favorise que
depuis les rives du Sud il y ait des
gens qui soient des intervenants qui
viennent semer ces troubles là où c'est
aux états de négocier avec d'autres
États ou des systèmes de réciprocités ou
des accords préalables je suis pour que
l'Union européenne aujourd'hui révise
Schengen pour faire un petit Schengen
pour qu'à l'échelle 4 5 ou 6 pays nous
puissions avoir une force qui a nos
frontières puissent nous prémunir de
cela et ensuite on verra comment de
nouveau élargir Schengen et que l'on
constitue ou reconstitue une force
puissante au niveau de Frontex pour
surveiller tous ceux qui tenteraient de
manière clandestine de faire des
passages entre les rives-sud de la
Méditerranée et les rivages du Nord
Christian strozier Emmanuel Macron
souhaite que des étrangers s'installer
dans les zones rurales pour les
repeupler vous avez écrit au ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin pour vous
opposer à cette idée pourquoi vous y
êtes opposé en réalité c'est pas une
opposition ferme c'est une je demande à
ce que nous puissions avoir une sorte de
codécision entre préfet par le monter et
mer sur les métiers en tension si dans
la ruralité il y a par exemple un
agriculteur un éleveur qui n'arrive pas
à recruter nous avons qu'aujourd'hui
qu'on a du mal à pourvoir à un certain
nombre d'emplois un hôtelier dans les
zones touristiques de la ruralité ou un
restaurateur qui disent moi je suis prêt
à accepter deux emplois qualifiés de
nationalité étrangères pour pouvoir
répondre à mes besoins
on aurait un conseil local à l'échelle
locale qui respecterait au fond cet
esprit des centralisation pourquoi pas
et dans le monde urbain nous savons
combien nous avons d'activités
professionnelles qui
manque d'emploi et qui ne sont pas
pourvus aujourd'hui cette question des
métiers en tant que c'est une bonne
décision parce que la droite dit que
c'est un projet de régularisation
massive vous vous dites pas ça mais vous
dites il faut que les maires soient
associés je suis très favorable à partir
du moment où c'est une décision d'une
commission locale auquel les maires ont
leur mot à dire aux côtés du monde de
l'économie des chambres de commerce et
d'industrie des unions patronales où
nous puissions décider au cas par cas
sur les métiers en tension sur un autre
sujet la structure bleu blanc rouge i
love Nice est devenu un symbole de la
ville après l'attentat de 2016 or une
association qui entend défendre la
langue française a saisi la justice pour
qu'elle ne s'appelle plus i love Nice
comment avez-vous réagi en apprenant ça
un c'est une pantalonade conduit par des
individus qui s'attaquent aux déviance
policières et je trouve que
certains
journaux locaux feraient bien de ne pas
leur accorder l'importance qu'il ne
mérite pas aujourd'hui
c'est s'attaquer d'abord une oeuvre
d'art qui est signée par un artiste
niçois qui s'appelle Gilles poignard
et pour moi qui est toujours accordé
beaucoup de liberté à l'expression de
l'art dans l'espace public comme nulle
part ailleurs comme de partout
je dis qu'aujourd'hui vous savez ça me
rappelle des temps anciens ou quand on
s'attaquait à l'art surtout lorsqu'il
s'agit depuis six ans alors amis six ans
ces gens-là pour se réveiller
alors que vous savez très bien monsieur
Caro vous qui avez souvent rendu hommage
à cette oeuvre qui était là pour
soutenir les familles des victimes de
l'attentat du 14 juillet
2016 à Nice que il y a des millions et
des millions de gens des artistes parmi
les plus prestigieux des chefs d'État
par les plus prestigieux qui se sont
emparés de cette œuvre pour témoigner
leur amour à Nice et aujourd'hui qui est
des espèces de d'individus du luberlu
qui aujourd'hui voudrait menacer cela je
pense que ça ne mérite pas qu'on leur
donne autant des coups merci Christian
Estrosi merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité regarde les deux une Denis ce
matin aujourd'hui sur les soignants
faut-il les réintégrer et puis celle de
Nice c'est le théâtre dans la reine
Denis voilà vos deux une merci beaucoup
Denis carro merci Christian Estrosi on
passe au club des territoires